Speaker 1: OK, now this we have to discuss
the newest idea for Trump to crowbar his way
back into power is that he could run for a
seat in the House of Representatives in twenty,
twenty two.
And then if he wins, he could try to become
the speaker of the House of Representatives
and then as speaker of the House, he could
then impeach Joe Biden.
This is something that Wayne Allen Root asked
Donald Trump about on his radio show late
last week when Alan Root has been a guest
on this show a bunch of times.
And it's been pretty wacky every time.
You can check that out on our YouTube channel
if you're interested.
And Trump seemed interested in this, that
that it was really an idea worth considering.
Take a look at this video.
Speaker 3: Why not?
Instead of just waiting for twenty twenty
four and I'm hoping you run in twenty twenty
four.
But why not, why not run in twenty twenty
two for the United States Congress.
A House seat in Florida when big lead us to
a dramatic landslide victory, taking the House
by 50 seats and then you become the speaker
of the House, lead the impeachment of Biden
and start criminal investigations against
Biden.
You'll wipe them out for his last two years
and he'll be president.
Speaker 2: Do it.
You know, it's very interesting.
You'll be a folk hero.
And people have said people have said run
for the Senate, run for the Senate.
But you know what your idea might be.
But it's very
Speaker 1: interesting.
Now, this is actually something that Steve
Bannon has floated before, the idea of Trump
running for Congress or maybe even Senate,
but Congress and then figuring out, OK, now
what what can we do about Joe Biden?
Bannon spoke to the Boston Republicans back
in February and said Trump could run for the
House, quote, We totally get rid of Nancy
Pelosi.
And the first act of President Trump as speaker
will be to impeach Joe Biden for his illegitimate
activities of stealing the presidency.
So Bannon's already been thinking along these
lines.
Now, the funniest part about this, I have
to tell you, is that Trump could run for speaker
of the House without being a member of Congress.
I know this might sound strange, but our friend
of the show, Bill Share, pointed this out,
tweeting, quote, Why are Republicans telling
Trump he should run for the House to become
speaker?
You don't have to be a House member to be
speaker.
It's a whole lot easier to just demand to
be speaker.
The House Republican Party would cancel McCarthy
faster than the Dixie Chicks.
Now, this is true.
It's true that you don't have to be a member
of the House to be speaker of the House.
But tradition does play a big role.
Bill Share is technically right.
The speaker of the House in the United States
is not legally required to be an elected member
of the House of Representatives.
But if you look at the Articles of the Confederation,
which predate the Constitution, it does say
that the Congress of the United States has
the power to, quote, appoint one of their
number to preside.
So it doesn't have to be that way.
Just I could be speaker of the House.
You could be speaker of the House without
being a member if the members of the House
do select you.
But needless to say, let's not give Donald
Trump this idea.
I don't actually expect Donald Trump to run
for the house if he did.
It's certainly plausible that if he won and
Republicans took the House in 2022, you could
maybe see Republicans choose Donald Trump
as speaker of the House.
But the funniest thing for me, there's two
really funny things about this for me.
One, if Trump hated being president because
everybody kept asking him to do stuff when
he just wanted to watch TV, he would despise
being a member of the House.
You actually sort of have to do some more
stuff than as president.
If you're a member of the House, you're expected
to show up in your district and do some constituent
work, although, you know, maybe if it's Trump,
he wouldn't be expected to do that.
That's number one.
That's funny.
But then the really funny thing is this idea
conflicts with Trump being back in power in
August.
In other words, why would Trump run for House
of Representatives in November of twenty twenty
two if he's going to be president again in
August of twenty twenty one, as is now being
widely reported, that he believes the one
way that this could backfire is if Trump decides
to run for a House seat, especially on a plan
of becoming House speaker.
And it does seem to me that it could backfire
in that if Trump's running for the House,
I think Democrats get really active.
We've been talking about who is going to be
able to get the vote out in the upcoming twenty,
twenty two midterms.
And in general, it's not good for the party
that takes over the White House, partially
because they are sort of happy and satisfied
that they've taken over the White House.
Two years later.
They tend to stay home more than the opposite
party so that.
Favors Republicans if Trump's running for
the House.
I think it reinvigorates Democrats and Democrats
come out and vote, vote, vote in twenty twenty
two in a way that would probably not be so
good for Republicans.
That's just my thought.
Let me know what you think and tell me if
you agree that Trump would absolutely hate
being a member of the House